[Music]
I'm about one month in from um
discovering that my husband of 11 years
uh was cheating ah man I'm so sorry are
there any kids involved yeah there is uh
we have three three daughters oh
[Music]
boy what is going on this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
[Music]
man I'm so glad you've joined us we're
talking about your mental and emotional
health we're talking about your marriage
your parenting your kids schools work
whatever you got going on in your life
my promise is I'm going to sit with you
and this show's about real people going
through real stuff I'm going to sit with
you and we're going to figure out what
happens next what's your next right move
in a world gone completely mad
completely
mad um hey the this is still I think is
this still the first week we still out
yeah still the first week so um go pick
up your copy well I mean bu in 40 weeks
if you want to but go pick up building a
non-ex live right now at john.com or
anywhere books are sold we're still in
that first week and we're hoping to hit
number one on the bestseller list and
things are looking great but go pick up
your copy pick up your copy and forget
the stupid bestseller list I want you to
pick up the book cuz I think it's a
great road map for building a
non-anxious life and if you are
wondering like I don't think I'm anxious
or I think I'm super overwhelmed anxious
and delone is always talking about this
or this or this we've got you we created
100% free anxiety test it's not
diagnostic this is not something you
take and you're like I've got such and
such anxiety disorder generalized
anxiety disorder or some kind of phobia
not what it is but it is it's a test
that will help you
identify oh here's a couple of areas
where I really need to head towards the
alarms my body's trying to get my
attention and one of these areas or two
of these areas or like me I took it
recently and in a lot of areas um your
body's trying to get your attention in
this test really helps kind of point you
in the right direction so go to John
del. anxiety test is that right uh yes
SL anxiety test and if you come back in
the next episode the team we all took it
yeah we're all taking it we're going to
talk about our results my results were
not great mine were actually better than
I expected oh yeah yeah you work with me
and so they should be we're worse than I
expected cuz I with blah blah blah yes
so um hey by the way we don't even ask
for your email address on this deal this
is just a give this is just us um we
don't have any of your info we don't
want any of your info this is simply
giving you a road mapap too oh man it
might point in this direction or that
maybe I need to focus on loneliness
maybe I need to focus on health and
healing some of these other areas so
check it out john.com anxiety test
totally free give don't even want your
email address um check it out all right
let's go out to St Louis Missouri and
talk to kayn what's up
kayin hi Dr John what's
happening oh your classic catchphrase is
partying so I guess you could say
partying oh that means not good at
all no no the sun is shining it's a it's
a great day oh no you've gone to weather
to make yourself feel good it must be
really bad what happened what's up um
well I'm I'm currently about um I guess
time frame wise I'm about one month in
from um discovering that my husband of
11 years uh was cheating ah man I'm so
sorry yeah and um I've I've got a kind
of multi-prong question here so just
bear with me um but I think the big
biggest thing is just how do I process
the grief of that betrayal yeah um how
do I cope with
the continued dishonesty um in the the
days following um you know we're as I
said a months out and um there continues
to
be um you know lies and
inconsistencies and some gaslighting in
my
opinion um are there any kids
involved yeah there is uh we have three
three daughters oh
boy and
unfortunately he's also a part of a
family business um with my side of the
family which makes this a little bit
more
complicated because there seems to be a
little bit more um stake involved for
other you know family members and I'm
struggling a little bit with the lack of
family support from ones that I had
expected it to come
from um
But ultimately um again the sun is
shining right and there's always a new
day hold on hold let's don't do that
let's don't do that I don't want to just
blow past how devastating this is and
you've added a couple layers um often
when we think yeah when we think about
cheating we think about like this very
very intimate personal
betrayal right but we often don't
realize until it's upon
us
that our whole world has
exploded down to who makes who makes
lunches for the kids and who's going to
drive them and how do we switch off to
in your
case I thought my dad would be on my
side on this deal or I thought my
brother you know I mean so I mean for
you you're losing everything
right yes that's what it feels like so
the sun might be shining and I I
appreciate the
sentiment right but it is raining all
over your your
life right and that's okay trying well
trying is good but I don't want you to
gloss over it because your body's going
to continue to solve
for the shenanigans that is everything
right now yeah there's a lot of
craziness yes yes um she understatement
what happened in in your marriage what
happened I I don't really know when I've
asked him about the why
um I mean because initially in the first
week that was just why you know my only
thought was just why why why why this
over us you know why did you pick this
over and over over
us um you know and he says it was for
excitement um he felt like I didn't want
him around
anymore um we stopped saying we loved
each other I guess and is what he said
I I don't really feel that though I mean
were we in a season of life where we
were disconnected certainly we have
three young very very young kids um you
know and you know we were in the
day-to-day hustle and the grind but we
were still communicating and I mean I
guess I couldn't have been more shocked
I felt like
he had been living a double
life um so you're speaking as though you
felt these things in the past tense and
then you got some new information to
realize oh he wasn't living a double
life you were just a terrible terrible
person to be married to and all of this
makes sense
now I've had a month
to how I I process some of it so I think
that's helped me realize that yeah you
probably were a little shady you know
for a while since you've been doing this
you know for quite some
time um I believe he was doing it longer
than he says but I've got no proof of
that and honestly it probably doesn't
matter anyway it's it's done
now um did you move
out no I I asked him to give me some
time and space
while we kind of figured things out and
we are working with a a marriage
counselor we do have different
goals um with that marriage counselor um
he wants to try to make it work I would
like to you know move past this so that
we can uh you know just co-parent
effectively and not you know traumatize
our our children um you know and be
emotionally mature
adults I I can't tell if you're in a
State of
Shock or if you have settled because
your your a is is not congruous with the
words you're
using um does well I probably trying to
do the steps that feel right that I know
should should be okay you know the
things that I should do um but I mean
there is a lot of shock
certainly okay um and I think I'm just
trying to process it you know day to
day um but I'm trying to be the most
logical um I mean that's just my nature
I'm Type A I'm I'm kind of a planner
anyway so my fear is you are you have
sealed up the um pressure relief valves
so tight so that you can make what you
think in the moment is a Ral
decision that you
implode or really
explode um have you said out loud I'm
not going to be your wife anymore you
took this from us and so now I'm going
to take control of my life moving
forward have you said those words out
loud no not to that effect I mean not
not that
specifically um but I've I've said you
know here's this I've set boundaries in
place for these are the times when you
need to be at the house so that you
can the the kids need to see you um
obviously at we know we still need hope
need help around the home we we have a
very very little one um at home he may
need to hire that
help cuz what he did was he made some
choices that going to have some
significant consequences both because he
lost his
family and he lost um the picture he
lost he lost everything and it's going
to come with some significant financial
consequences
and in my my fear is in an effort to
make everything rational and simple and
still you're going to end up getting
dragged under water because things are
not still the waters you're in the
middle of a
hurricane MH and so when you're in the
middle of a hurricane often I me let me
just say it this way unless it's
something I specifically have trained
for so for instance if somebody's um
comes running into the office right now
and says so and so's um on top of the
building about to kill thems I've
trained for that I know what that I I
know the protocol
there um other than that like or in in
similar situations Bonker situations
like that other than that if somebody
was to come hurt my wife let's
say I will Outsource Outsource my
rational
decisionmaking to an attorney and to the
police department and to a couple of
close friends and colleagues that I have
um High trust
in because if I don't honor those
feelings in that
season my body's going to
implode and my kids are going to think
I'm insane and they're going to think
they're
insane see what I'm saying right it's
almost like you're trying to keep
everything so cool so cool so cool and
everything inside your guts knows this
is not
cool what's happening with his family
business uh well he works with my father
and why isn't your father thrown him out
fired him
immediately because it's coming on their
busy time of year uh where it's
not um I guess it wouldn't be at you
know his best interest to do that right
now um you know it comes before the best
interest of my daughter nothing right
right I no
things
right yeah I hope you sit in how
disgusting that is is and don't
wallpaper over that too that's the
second most important man of your life
that's let you down and I would tell
that to his face if he was standing
right here I don't care how busy
whatever crap season's coming
up right I could care
less I I I agree I mean I know that on
this yes that's what it looks like um
and it feels like that that's what it is
yeah I I know what kind of business do
they
run um
agriculture so they they Farm
together I just can't
imagine cannot
imagine my daughter having three baby
girls and her husband cheating on her a
bunch then clocking in for work what's
up man well John if you want to feel um
I guess even more confused um add this
to the dynamic um my fathers told me
that he doesn't believe it was cheating
because it was not
physical because it was sexting um there
was a lot of conversations had over
um um different social media platforms
and different apps yeah so in my dad's
standpoint he doesn't agree that it was
physical and when I explain to him that
the marriage counselor has validated my
thoughts that yes it is
cheating
um our marriage counselor um is a a
Christian based counselor and actually
explains it in the Bible you
know um I don't hey I I don't care if
you are seeing like an atheist Satanist
right they would agree that this
isid right Compass knows better it is
super
rare I don't have any data on this okay
so whatever but it is rare that somebody
has
multiple engagements with
people that start sending photos and
there's nothing
else very
rare and you know that and I know
that right I me it's just it's dishonest
I mean the the and then not what I've
explained to my father and you know I
mean at the end of the day your father
has cashed down your father cashed out
right thank you he chose his bro over
his
daughter thank you for V validating that
that means a lot I hate that for
you cuz when your husband does you wrong
there should be that one guy left in
your
corner and um I've never experienced
this but I've just sat with enough
sexual assault victims over
time that they tell me one of the most
important things is when they tell the
story finally that the first person they
tell them believes
them and one step removed from sexual
assault this violation that somebody
took something from me the next step is
somebody took something from you
somebody took your family away cuz they
just need some excitement wanted to feel
alive a little
bit and and Kaylin you just weren't
doing your part I know you're raising
those three babies but you just you know
kind of weren't pulling your weight
around here making me feel
special
and you sat down with your dad and he
looked at you and said I don't believe
you I believe that
guy and I've never been in your shoes
but from the narratives I've heard from
sitting with countless women in that
situation I'm
sorry
the question you have to live with I
mean live into is what are you going to
do
next and it sounds like the two men that
should have been there for you chose
each other and chose deception and chose
dishonesty and by doing so they chose to
no longer be in relationship with
you that's going to hurt hurt hurt hurt
hurt it it does and I think my logical
brain knows that the only way forward is
divorce I I don't see how we can rebuild
the trust the
respect it's possible you can rebuild it
but you got to tell the truth first and
he's not so far that hasn't happened
correct and and
that's
yeah
um and it's going to be hard it's going
to get harder before it gets any easier
I know that but I'm the lack of family
support makes it more there's no family
support and let's be real real like
brass haacks being a single mom with
three girls three little kids is a
nightmare
financially like just dayt day it's
challeng yeah it'll be challenging
yeah
yep yeah and that list listen to me
carefully you've got to have a group of
women that will walk alongside you
during
this I wish that would be your family
but it sounds like it's
not I have some family members that that
will um my mom's been really supportive
but that's hard for their marriage
because she is still married to well
they're grownups that's that's for them
to deal with that's not for you no I
yeah right but you also need a couple of
women in your life that are not um your
best buddies
M also you're 30 days out and I think a
separation is good I don't think this
has to end in divorce doesn't have to
they can if you wanted
to um you're not
crazy but I feel crazy sometimes I know
because the people around you are
gaslighting you so bad you can't see
straight yeah
right if I send naked pictures to
somebody else or vice versa
that's cheating on my wife period period
it just is just
is yep and nobody wants to see naked
pictures of me still I put that out
there but if I do that as cheating and
anybody tells you otherwise is just
trying to has ulterior
motives yep I I
agree I hate this for you hate this for
you I hate this for you I hate this for
you
the hard part on calls like this Kaylin
is there's no
easy just go do these three
things you're doing the right things
right now you're meeting with a
counselor you're talking to your mom who
trusts you and believes you soundss like
you need to get a couple of women that
you say hey I need to meet with y'all
once a week every
Monday you need to sit down with your
analytical brain and be very clear about
the financial need needs that you need
right now in your
home and that could include someone to
help out with the kids that could
include somebody to help out with um
like housework and things like that and
your husband gets to pick up that
Tab and you're going to have to explore
the really uncomfortable lot like
everything in your life got dumped over
life change of going to get a job going
to find work and figuring out what that
means and what that looks like and how
that's going to work out your town and
all like your qualifications all
that here's the the challenge with an
analytical brain the approach you're
taking there's a challenge with an over
emotional right it's just ah and it's
just hard to even make a rational Choice
you've hit the hit the pendulum so far
the other
way the hard part with a rational choice
is you don't feel
it and you try to just make sure
everything's smooth which
without meaning to you end up conceding
to things for the sake of Peace you keep
this Peacekeeper role which you've
probably had for a long time and you
just try to get to the next quick second
and the next 30 minutes and the next 30
minutes which is life with three little
kids that's also a mindset they've
studied mind uh folks with poverty
mindset they've studied folks with a
wealth mindset those who can look past
tomorrow that's how you begin to
separate yourself financially and if I'm
worried about where my next meal comes
from and my next meal comes from I'm
always just worried about where my next
meal is coming from not when I start
worrying about where my grandkids meals
are going to come from and so you're
going to have to get some people with
you to help you feel your way through
this and not just try to logic your way
through it and logic your way through it
there's going to be some moments when
you have to Outsource your logic to an
attorney to a therapist what do I do
next and they're going to say you need
to have this hard conversation or that
hard conversation and you're going to
have to spend some time maybe you write
yourself letters maybe you started
journaling I I'd really strongly
recommend that actually and make it a
daily practice I'm going to write down
how I
feel because if you bottle that up like
a nuclear reactor your daughters are
going to feel it you're going to feel it
everyone around you will feel it and
you're going to be trying to be cool as
a cucumber that's just a recipe for
combustion and people with a rational
analytical mind are always trying to get
things back to the way they
were need to get things I need to get
this divorce over so that everything can
be smooth I just need to get this over
so everything can be smooth I just need
to tell this have this one conversation
and give this um dollar amount that I
need over so that everything can be
smooth there is no going back to the way
things were everything's different now
everything's different
now and husband if you're watching this
the only chance you have at
reconciliation and building something
new you got to tell the truth all of it
all of it starting now and dads if your
daughters come to
you believe them we'll be right
back hey what's up good folks delone
here listen researchers tell us that the
average person spends about a third of
their life sleeping that's about a
quarter of a million hours and we know
this for certain restoring your mind and
body with sleep is crucial to your
physical emotional and relational health
so if you're going to be sleeping for
onethird of your life and sleep is
critical for every good thing you've got
going on why not try to get the best
sleep possible and great sleep starts
with an amazing mattress like dreamcloud
dreamcloud mattresses are soft cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night I know because some of my
family sleeps on dreamcloud and here's
another bit of research for you four out
of five people say they fall asleep
faster on their dreamcloud than they did
on their old mattress and right now John
delone show listeners can get an awesome
deal 40% off all mattresses plus an
extra savings of $50 go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter promo code John
deloney that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
promo code John
delone all right we're back let's go out
to Washington DC and talk to Lee what's
up
Lee hi Dr John how are you doing great
how about
you I'm doing great thank you for taking
my call you got it what's
up okay so about a week and a half ago
my really good longtime friend lost her
sibling uh tragically in a car accident
and they were really close um also in
recent years another immediate family
member of hers uh one of her parents um
unexpectedly passed away so our family
has kind of have been druged through
like all the levels of hell that no one
should have to go through just in the
past couple of years so last week was
the siblings visitation and funeral at
the funeral I saw a lot of old friends
we spent a lot of our 20s with you know
doing the usual 20s something things and
so we gathered in a group in the back of
the visitation room and proceeded to
talk laugh and carry on about times in
our 20s you know people's new kids
divorces work all the topics that you
would catch up on with someone like more
at a bar or out to lunch and I didn't
realize until probably 10 minutes in
that we were all receiving stairs from
people in the room it was kind of like
we had totally forgotten where we were
and that there wasn't an open casket in
the front of the room and our friend and
her family weren't heavily grieving um
Lee you're the worst you're the worst
friend ever I'm totally kidding totally
kidding well you know a child lost its
parent and we were kind of carrying on
really loudly um obviously not on
purpose but that night I woke up in the
middle of the night just feeling super
sick to my stomach that I may have
actually really hurt my friend and her
family um my friend's like the most
genuine and kind person I've ever met in
my life in 15 years she's never said a
bad word about anybody have you called
her
um well that's my question um so the
next day at the funeral no one mentioned
anything about it uh but of course my
question for you is is do I go and
apologize to her do I even say
anything um I think about it I I've been
you I've done that exactly what you're
talking about and for me it's twofold
number one that's how I handle grief as
I laugh or I handle that discomfort
okay um and it's probably just hanging
out with first responder is too long but
it it's a it's a very blue dark black
sense of
humor the second thing is um is I have a
picture in my head and I have forever of
my funeral I want everybody laughing
their heads off I even wrote out what I
want to happen at my funeral with a
couple of friends having to sing certain
karaoke songs just so everyone would
laugh my wife said I'm not doing any of
that stuff I'm not doing chores for you
and you're dead but but like I I that's
my picture and I
also have realized over time that's not
everybody else's picture right and so
I've been you what I would do in your
situation is are you all in the same
town yes okay I would just say hey can I
take you to
coffee and it's not about absolving
yourself you don't want her and her
grief to have to take care of you right
now but I do think it's a good moment to
check in on
her um usually after the funeral after
someone loses especially a child or a
sibling a close sibling it's that 30
days sometimes I'll put a star on my
calendar a week out and then 30 days out
and then maybe again six months out
because that's when things get real real
quiet and you reaching out a week after
two weeks after and saying hey can we go
get coffee and you just using that time
how are you and if it comes up
naturally say hey we saw a bunch of old
friends we were being so obnoxious and
I'm so
sorry and that will give her an
opportunity to say yeah I heard that
you're the
worst or she'll say I I was so in my
black hole that I didn't even realize it
I'm glad y all got to catch
up which is I think about 95% of people
would say the
latter okay and I'm glad you mentioned
you know reaching out and that was kind
of my next question is um you know we
had plans to go and do these really fun
things um you know for fall and for
winter do I still invite her out to do
okay absolutely
yes my mom said that she's never going
to be the same after this so I'm kind of
she's an adult she get she gets to she's
an adult and she gets to decide what she
does
next okay what we don't want to do is
create artificially create lone
loneliness in her
life as she's struggling for the words
to say the things that she even needs
what she
wants um we don't want to just quote
unquote give her space and all a sudden
her whole network shuts off thinking
they're helping
out I would give her an opportunity to
say I'm not ready for that right
now okay and you need to just know every
time you reach out and say hey um I
think it all starts with a cup of coffee
or just go grab a drink and just hang
out
um but I think every time you invite her
on that weekend trip every time you
invite her to that Airbnb every time you
invite her to that concert if she says
no just know that has nothing to do with
you she's just grieving and struggling
and some some days in her grief um will
be up days and some days she's not going
to want to get out from from under the
coverage and that's cool and maybe you
skip the weekend retreat and say hey if
I brought over a bunch of cheeseburgers
and some shows you just want to watch
Ted lasso runs and she might be like yes
and she might say I just need some time
about
myself okay is that you see what I'm
saying yeah that makes sense and I'll
tell you I mean I tell everybody this
but so
often we we have no um we have no road
map for sitting with people who are
hurting because of loss or because of
cancer because of
whatever that we all end up leaning on
the hurting person to make us feel
better because we don't know what to do
with our
discomfort and I would tell you just to
be real cognizant of not using
her and her going out with you her and
her saying it's okay that you all were
causing a scene in the back of the
room like it's not her job to prop you
all up right now it's vice versa it's
her friend's job to come hold her arms
up in the desert because she can't
breathe see the
difference I do and that's why I asked
the question because again in my mind
it's like I I hope I didn't cause her
any more pain than what she's already
going through you probably
didn't you probably
didn't okay you probably didn't I'd be
willing to bet you
didn't you might have bothered her aunt
so and so or whatever um but she doesn't
get a vote and maybe you did maybe she's
going to be really UPS set with you and
if she is so be it I mean at that point
what do you say you say like I'm really
sorry right like I didn't have like I
got uncomfortable and I saw some old
friends and it was easy to distract
myself I just didn't handle it right I'm
sorry I mean what else you gonna say
right well that's the truth yeah I was
super uncool and I'm
sorry okay if it were my
friends and I lost one of my
siblings and a bunch of my friends
showed up and they were in the back
laughing I would be grateful for
that so everybody's going to respond
differently I think the thing to not do
is avoid your friend I think is to head
directly into that discomfort and just
put all out on the table but only after
you spent some time saying hey how are
you the week after the funeral the month
after the funeral the 6 months after the
funeral after all of the emails and card
stop and all of the condolences stop and
the bills get paid and the insurance
stuff comes through after all that it
gets really really
quiet real
quiet and that's when the real friends
show up not the hangers on and the high
fivers and the peripheral friends who
legitimately feel bad that you lost a
child or that you're sick or that you
know that your sibling passed away
they're really sad but they move on
your Rider dies those you're really
close to it affects yall y'all's life is
different now
too and like I say I will put a star in
my calendar for a week out sometimes a
month out sometimes six months out and
just make sure I reach out cu things get
real
quiet so reach out tell you want take
her to coffee and if she says I don't
want to go with you I don't want to go
with you and you reach out in another
week I don't want to go with you reach
out another week I don't want to go with
you then you could say hey are you are
we cool are we cool and then maybe
she'll say no you're a jerk you were
laughing at my at my sibling's funeral
and you can say I'm sorry I didn't
handle that right I was weirded out and
I was uncool I saw some old friends I
was
uncool and then she gets to heal on her
own but I don't think that's going to be
the case she's lucky to have you Lee
she's lucky to have you reach out we'll
be right
back hey good folks deloney here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right let's go out to Upstate
New York and talk to the mighty Joseph
what's up
Joseph hey how you doing man we're
rocking man thank you so much I'm glad
that you're with us man what's up so
I've uh I'm at this Crossroads in my
life where I can't really figure out how
to uh move on from actions that I've
done or the person I was to the person
I've became long story as short as
possible um I was married and had five
beautiful kids with this woman and uh I
I I wasn't a man yet I was stuck in this
little boy mentality still I never grew
up I didn't learn how to be emotionally
open I got an active addiction and
mental health
untreated and she got the worst part of
me for almost eight years before the
divorce and uh after the divorce uh we
started to move on and I started dating
and when I started dating and and
growing and going to counseling and
getting my relationship right with God I
saw a complete 180 from the man I was
before and uh now every time I get kind
of close to someone and start really
giving them the best part of me after
four years of healing and growth I I
I've started to realize that you know
I'm being a man for for women who is not
the mother of my child you know mother
of my children and I'm just uh it's it's
causing me to not be able to fully
commit to people because I feel really
guilty and ashamed that the uh the woman
who birthed five beautiful kids for me
got you know the terrible end of the
deal and I just get in my head about
what would happen if if uh you know she
had received a the man that I am today
the one that's able to communicate the
one that's emotionally open the one that
has a relationship with God that she
always wanted me to have with her the
relationship with God you know I'm with
the I'm with a new woman now for six
months and you know it's not by any
means a perfect relationship but we pray
together in the morning we pray together
in the afternoon we do church services
we uh put God first in our relationship
we communicate effectively all things
that you know my wife of 8 years was
starving for and begging me for
are you still struggling with
addiction uh I actually have four years
sober now okay and uh I've been back
right with God for about hold hold on
hold on what what's your
replacement so my replacement was God uh
I I entered God back into my life and uh
I replaced it more with uh dealing with
my problems effectively instead of
masking my problems so I use God and the
Bible and a um a Christian
uh way of life to replace the things
that I didn't like about myself I used
God to kind of replace those things with
better attributes so that I didn't have
to have the feeling of having to
disassociate from the reality I was
living I think you're still
disassociated and I want you to prove to
me that I'm wrong
okay right now you are punishing
yourself in the present for things that
you did in the
past is that
helping yes it is helping how's that
helping I mean it's not helping but I is
there anything you can do right now is
there anything you can do to yourself
when it comes to fogging or punishing
yourself it's going to get you back
those eight
years no
no and when I say it sounds like you're
still disassociating I think the
discomfort is coming less from this
guilt over how you treated this woman
for years ago and up to 12 years
ago I think you're scared that you're
going to fail
again
definitely and so she this this guilt
this it feels like it's imaginary it
feels like a place to put your hurt on
to without having to look in the mirror
and say I don't trust that guy
yet I agree is that fair
it's 100% fair and
accurate I don't I I I just don't think
you're avoiding commitment because of
the guilt of your of your wife I think
you're avoiding commitment because
you're scared to death that you're not
going to be who you want to be and so
it's s like the way you're talking about
all this Christian stuff good I'm glad
that you found faith I'm glad that you
found a set of practices I'm glad glad
you found Common Ground I'm glad for all
that
stuff but you know as well as I do that
can become really performing
ative yes as a way to sing and
dance and it's a it's a fancy
sophisticated game of look over here
look over here look over
here while you looking in the mirror and
being and thinking that guy's
disgusting I do I do still beat myself
up a lot I know you do and uh you know I
and that tells me you're not really
unrealist standard but that tells me
you're not on the other side of
um it tells me you're not on the other
side of taking a knee and submitting
to I'm out of
control makes a lot of sense there's
Faith there's Faith
performance there's there's there's
religious practice that is a sense of
surrender and then there's Faith
practice as a form of control I'm going
to grab this wheel so tight I can see
the whites in my
Knuckles and that almost always ends in
deconstruction and Ash those that enter
into belief into Faith structures with
their hands
open it's I mean you you can you I mean
if you're watching this on YouTube you
can like watch my shoulder shoulders
drop faith and belief as a way of
leaning against God as
against something bigger than
yourself that is different than trying
to grasp hold of and take control of
something infinitely bigger than
you does that does that ring
true yeah definitely that's why just
asking you that's why I just ask like
what what did you trade because it does
sound like you're on the other side what
was your addiction of choice what was
your numbing agent of choice alcohol
alcohol sounds like you put the bottle
away so you're four years without a
drink yes sir uh do you work 90 hours a
week or do you have a healthy work
balance uh about 70 hours a week out of
town uh that was another thing I I tried
to get away from all these emotions and
took my local job over the road and I'm
about 3,000 miles away from everybody
right now there you
go so you did a noble thing you got out
of the bar right very very hard very
hard very Noble I'm super proud of
you and you force gped it you just get
running is that fair definitely
okay and I think you're running from
you that's very fair I always run for me
and uh you know I I don't to lie I hold
myself to this higher expectation than I
hold other people I definitely don't cut
myself any slack or you know I always
feel this sense of
inadequacy um in everything I do be at
work or being a father or being in a
relationship or the marriage when I was
in it I I guess I always feel like
whatever I do it's never going to be
enough it's never going to be you know
who are you trying to form
for I I can never differentiate if I'm
actually selflessly doing it for the
other person or if I'm doing it for like
the status of my own self to make myself
feel
okay it's probably an exhausting thing
trying to parse that out instead of just
going to do the next right
thing because it's probably a mixture of
both
is that fair like sometimes I do the
dishes when there when the house is
bananas and my kids are all over the
place and my wife has driven four hours
in the car between us you know a cross
country meet and school and after school
play and violin like could and I'll do
the dishes to help my wife out to help
out the ecosystem of the house to help
out everything and it does make me feel
like I'm a good dad and a good husband
all that can be
true if I'm one of those weak husbands
that goes and does the dishes and then I
sit there like a puppy waiting for my
wife to Pat me on the head and tell me
I'm a good boy and if she doesn't I
pout that's lame but I think it's a
mixture of all of it and I think that's
okay do you paralyze yourself with
thinking and thinking and ruminating
over and over and over and over
again always I am the hugest overthinker
okay you know even in my current
relationship it could be something very
minuscule and I will overthink it to the
point that something so minor like a
small little blipping communication
turns into everything is destroyed
everything's wrong and I'm into like
survival mode time to fix things when
really it's just like two words that
need to be said was your childhood
chaos very much so yes
okay rumination is a complete and total
waste of your time
the only thing it proves it feels like
you are getting out ahead of things and
it feels like productive helpful
thinking and pre-planning it's not it's
uh it's another drink it's a way to not
feel the current
moment and a way to not make IR rational
decision about what comes next it's a
way to avoid all of
that it's a
drug that your body gets addicted
to and my guess is overthinking having
to think about what comes next kept you
safe as a kid is that
fair definitely it was a defense
mechanism of creating an out creating an
escape plan was your mom an
alcoholic no uh just a abusive household
with my mom and my dad very Tous
relationship with no communication just
physical interaction okay so you're
literally getting hit as a kid you have
to think two steps ahead of your old man
so you don't get his fist in your face
and your body comes up with a pattern on
how to solve and enter into and out of
relationships and it's by pre-planning
and pre-planning and and observing and
watching and and coming up with another
plan and another route and another route
and another route and you miss this
woman sitting next to you on the couch
saying hey can I just settle up next to
you because I love you you miss all
that exactly right are you in
communication with your five
kids yeah we FaceTime uh two to three
times a day and whenever I'm on home
time from work I actually uh stay in my
oldest son's room he has a futon and I
go right I have a very good co-parenting
relationship so I I talk to my kids a
couple times a day when I'm at work and
when I'm home it's all about them for
the week that I'm off of work every
month um your ex-wife y y'all y'all
still talk y'all act like grown-ups
and oh very much so we're actually
really good friends and we parent better
apart than we did together and and um
we're on such a good level you know we
talk about our current relationships and
we talk about the kids and we're even
there for each other on friendship
levels like if she needs something
that's outside the realm with kids or me
we're always there for each other um
okay do pretty good with that so it
sounds like she's forgiven
you and it sounds like she's made peace
with this is her
life and it sounds like um you've made
peace with this is your life sounds like
the only person that hasn't forgiven
Joseph is
Joseph that makes sense and at some
point you have to understand continuing
to look in the mirror and try to
outperform your dislike for
yourself will be a crash landing every
single
time you can't hate your body into going
into the gym to get in better shape you
can't hate your the way you look into to
dieting so that you lose weight you
can't hate yourself into being a better
husband you
can't you have to decide man I really
was struggling and I made some really
bad choices for half half a decade
ago I did and it cost me
everything and the greatest way I can
honor my ex-wife who's now a good friend
of mine who's a good co-parent who's a
good mother to all five of my
kids is to not make the same mistake in
future
relationships and that doesn't start
with singing and dancing that starts
with being a good Steward of the man in
the
mirror I'm going to take care of his
mental and emotional health I'm going to
take care of his relationships I'm going
to take care of his physical
body how much money do you make at your
job what's your annual
income uh roughly 65 to 70,000 I want
you to quit that job and find a $60,000
job in your local community that you
don't have to be on the road so much
stop
running you could probably make 65,000
as a manager of a
McDonald's and I'm saying that half I'm
saying that half um half with a wink I
know it's easy for me just to lob that
I'm just a podcaster like quit your job
man but I want you to start reimagining
you know when you did you go to AA when
you first got
sober I did and I still go to Virtual
meetings for those I still work a
virtual 12-step program you are living
your life at arms
length you go to Virtual AA most of your
interactions with your kids are
virtual most of your interactions with
your current six-month girlfriend is in
your
head you're going to have to make peace
with being present with people in the
room looking you in the eye and that
probably is pretty uncomfortable huh it
is I have like a overwhelming sense of
anxiety when that happens okay you got
to head into those storms otherwise
you're going to create an entirely
virtual world that feels real but it's
not and your body's going to shut you
down
okay definitely that makes a lot of
sense when you first go to AA what do
they tell you you're going to lose your
friends you're going to lose your
environment you're going to lose the bar
where everybody knows your
name and your life is worth it right
that's what they say
yes you're there part
two now you have to be stop you have to
find environments where you're not
running all the time you have to find
environments where you have to be
present and you have to feel that
anxiousness and remind yourself I'm
worthy of being love and I'm worthy of
being
here and when those old stories pop
up I'm not who I once was thank God I've
grown by the way Joseph we all have I
don't know anybody who's super thrilled
with who they were 14 years
ago I don't know anybody I think Jenna
was eight but I don't think any of us
are happy with who we were 14 years ago
thank God that we get to grow and learn
new things and thank God for grace and
forgiveness and new friends and to
Circle all the way back around your
religious practices are good man I'm
glad it's much better than going into a
bar but if you're using Rel religious
practices as a way to grab tight control
of your
life you're going to end up suffocating
yourself belief
Faith it's about letting go
into this love that's way way bigger
than you
are God is not something that you can
wrap your hands around and grab hold
of God is somebody you enter into their
presence and take a knee and they pick
you he picks you up and he hugs you so
tight you can hardly breathe and he says
I love you will you love you
too you have to love your enemies
too even when you're your worst
enemy thanks for the call we'll be right
[Music]
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show two
incredible feel-good
stories that have a little bit of advice
for all of
us this first one is from NPR in
2014 um trius Belmont was struggling
with depression her grandmother had just
died she and her longtime boyfriend had
just broken up life felt unbearable
around that time Belmont was teaching a
dance class she didn't have a driver's
license so friends and family would have
to give her rides one day her ride
didn't show up she waited for an hour
they never
came and she writes I just decided to
walk home it wasn't super far but longer
than I wanted to walk and I was having
one of the worst days of my life on the
way home I crossed over the 49 Bridge
it's a high bridge and I was looking
down at all the cars feeling so useless
like such a burden to everyone in my
life and I decided this is the time I'm
going to end my life I was sobbing and
crying and working up the courage to
just go through with it because I knew
at that moment I was going to make
everyone's life better and a car came
driving up from behind and they shouted
don't jump right as I was in my darkest
moment those words changed everything
for me having a stranger care about me
in my darkest time made it so I didn't
jump and it saved my
life from Good News movement 16-year-old
Jamie Harrington saw a man sitting on
the edge of a bridge and stopped to ask
are you
okay ah jeez Kelly it's going to make me
cry thinking of a 16-year-old boy
walking home my son's just a few
years just think about this close your
eyes if you're not
driving 16-year old boy just walking
home with a backpack on and um I don't
know singing some dumb song in his head
and he sees a man sitting on the edge of
a bridge and he stops and says hey are
you
okay and that one little question caused
that man to pause and he got
down after convincing the man to get
help the 16-year-old boy convinced the
man to get help they exchanged numbers
in parted ways months later the man
called
Jamie and he said him and his wife were
expecting a baby boy and they named the
baby
Jamie so when we have it's common and I
thought this for years and years and
years
um I'm not going to get involved if
someone's going to take their life
someone's goingon to die by suicide
because if I get involved if if someone
really wants to die they're going to
figure out another way to do it they're
going to they're going to find away
right and then that famous study about
folks who jumped off the Golden Gate
Bridge and
lived and I don't remember the number
but a high in the high 90s N More Than
90% of them went on to die of old age of
die of natural causes die of cancer
whatever later on down the
road what does that
mean they lived and the moment they
jumped they said ah what am I doing
nothing was this
big it doesn't always have to be suicide
sometimes it's your daughter sometimes
it's your husband sometimes it's your
friend it's your
coworker just saying hey I see you I
hope you're doing
okay sometimes it's a text to a friend
who lost a loved one a few months
ago and it just says I know today's
quiet and now you feel like nobody's
thinking about you I
am it might just be hey that's a cool
shirt you look good you look nice not in
a creepy weird way Ben but like in a hey
you look
nice we have a culture of let's don't
get involved that's their problems these
are my problems M your
business what if we what if we change
that and that's not a it's not going to
come for Washington it's not going to
come from a senator it's not going to
come from a teacher or whatever it's
just going to come from you saying hey
you look nice
saying hey it would make my day if I
could pay for your
groceries hey I had a really good month
I'm grabbing your gas at the
pump hey single mom I'm I'm paying for
all four
tires just been that kind of month for
us I'm GNA pass them along hey um are
you okay three words that have saved
more lives than almost any other three
words or maybe
I love
you whatever it
is
quietly and with kindness and
gentleness let's get involved let's be
the person in the car driving by saying
hey don't jump let's be the 16-year-old
kid saying hey are you
okay that's how the world's going to
change I love you guys thank you all for
joining us on today's show stay in
school don't do drugs be
nice make it make it a point today ask
somebody that you don't know that well
hey are you
okay we'll be right back love you
[Music]
guys